let's talk a little bit about this
upcoming election because it does sound
like our Fair Governor Carroll uh Rhonda
Santos is going to jump in probably in
the next couple days got a little info
here from your paper the New York Post
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis will
officially enter the race for president
next week the post has learned setting
up a much anticipated Face-Off with his
one-time Ally former president Donald
Trump after months of speculation about
a White House run DeSantis 44 will fire
the required paperwork with the Federal
Election Commission before holding an
announcement event in his hometown of
Dunedin according to Sunshine a Sunshine
State Legislative Source the prospective
filing coincides with a two-day meeting
between DeSantis and his donors in Miami
where attendees are being told they'll
be put to work the source added that
desantis's official announcement will be
followed by a staggered rollout of
endorsements that have been held in
reserve until he gets in the race the
DeSantis supporting Never Back Down pack
previously announced the Florida
governor has been endorsed by dozens of
legislators legislatures in early voting
states of Iowa and New Hampshire uh
Pedro the first part I want to mention
about that is the 44. he is 44 years old
I am 46 years old that means I'm older
than him we are used to be governed uh
being governed by you know people in
their late 70s 80s and and sometimes in
their 90s it's kind of refreshing isn't
it
yeah that was my first thought actually
when I was looking at that screen grab
was 44.
um and it's just so funny because this
DeSantis is DeSantis is basically the
the exact opposite of of what both Joe
Biden and Trump represent uh this kind
of um and I mean we're gonna get into
this but and part of it is precisely
that the santis is Being Framed as a
kind of Trojan Horse by by the Trump
campaign
um but right now you've got this kind of
funny situation where Trump who's
supposed to be the anti-establishment
guy is actually in many ways kind of
legitimizing the old sclerotic GOP
establishment and its ideas and on the
other hand you've got this young upstart
that actually threatens to kind of upset
the apple cart and that's for I mean
that seems to me pretty obvious why he's
so hated by the I mean the actual
establishment GOP which has fallen in
line behind Trump I mean it's a it's an
incredible situation because of the
level of gaslighting that's gone in to
convince you that the santis represents
the old order uh and and these two older
guys or I guess specifically Trump
represents the New Order